carton and the second series takes that
unfortunate hit which
you know still fires me up when i think
about it but
at the end should have been flagged
should have been fine right
you can say it they know anyway so um so
so we get in a situation there where
like we have to still
keep our priorities intact
tarry roseman eagles general manager i
tried oh i tried to get him in trouble
with the league office to get him to
publicly criticize the failure to flag
or find
seahawks defensive engineering clowney
for the hit on carson wentz that knocked
him out of the playoff game he didn't
bite
the eagles won that division it was a
division the cowboys
should have won could have won they had
in the palm of their hands
they blew it week 16 and a loss to the
eagles and the eagles held on to win at
week 17
and then lost obviously the next week in
the wild card round
at home do we think the eagles
and chris i'll start with you where are
the eagles in relation to last year are
they same
are they better are they worse you said
in relation to one of the other teams if
you aren't getting better you're getting
worse
what are the eagles getting i i think
they've gotten better
i do i mean listen you know we could
talk about the first two picks of the
draft right off the bat you know they
were a little controversial
sir certainly did we all agree with them
you know no
but i think they're going to help the
football team regardless i mean jalen
hurts we know is a weapon and gonna be
able to be used in a lot of different
ways jalen rieger
a little controversial is the 21st pick
uh but still
a guy that can make things with the ball
and his he happened with the ball in his
hands and get open to be a weapon for
carson wentz so i think between that
and then a sneaky really good free
agency
you know i i look at this division and i
just go yeah philadelphia is really good
they have a premier quarterback they
have a quarterback that i would say is
not in the top five of football
but he's somewhere in six through 10 and
carson wentz and
you know when you talk about javon
hargrave jatavis brown at linebacker
the darius slay trade you know a few
other things to sure up that secondary
that hasn't been that great the last few
years
i do look like the eagles i mean it
looks like the eagles got better and to
me it's eagles and cowboys in this
division i think they're
they stand above the other two
significantly in my opinion at this
point
yeah i would i'd absolutely agree other
than
uh i'd probably give the cowboys a
pretty good edge right now coming into
this season
you know i like a lot of what they've
done even though i thought that
they should have gone defense uh with
that first pick
um as as great as the receivers they
picked is the fact is
there's a good chance in my opinion
they're gonna be a top three top five
scoring team in the nfl this year if
that's the case if that's the case
i think it's going to be incumbent on
them in this
weird weird offseason to make sure that
this defense gets
built to the point that they can play
solid enough to support an outstanding
offense
and when i look at the eagles i look at
a team that
has had some mighty struggles in the
last two years
to finish nine and seven uh both years
and you know i think coming off their
super bowl they did
everything they could to keep everything
moving in the right direction
but in the nfl man you never ever stay
the same
you never pick up where you left off
exactly the previous year
and i think the eagles right now they've
made some significant improvements
um and and look the one other thing i
would say about this division
washington's front seven is going to be
really
really good and i mean
that could be the single best
facet of any team in in the nfc east
this year
i think their pass rush i think their
interior is really good
so they're going to be there hey listen
those two games against washington the
dallas and philly have this year
those are not going to that's not 2-0
for uh a two-and-oh gimme for
for each team yeah i mean it's not an
apples-to-apples comparison but when you
look at what nick bosa did as the second
overall pick last year for the 49ers
and what chase young could do as the
second overall pick for washington this
year
it it it cements that front seven and
if you can create havoc if you can
disrupt the opposing offense if you
can force turnovers get short fields get
more points
your offense is going to look a hell of
a lot better even though there are real
questions about that offense
and i think between washington and the
giants that gives them the edge as the
team that could rise up
in this division and chris i agree with
you you've got the haves and the
have-nots
the two at the top the two at the bottom
but i think washington does have
the better chance than the giants to
bridge that gap
and maybe disrupt the conversation the
presumption that it's going to be the
eagles or the cowboys winning the
division chris what do you think
well yeah i mean i i think washington's
going to be a i do think the whole
division got better i do i mean i expect
the new york giants to be a pain in the
butt too
certainly you know got some help on the
offensive line and now you're going to
be able to let daniel jones and saquon
barkley go
uh to to fulfill their complete ability
you know last year it's tough to be
really awesome when nobody's blocking
for you a lot of the time
but the washington redskins you know to
what you guys are saying i think you're
spot on
i mean they have a game-changing unit in
that defensive line i mean
it is a they will be able to play
through their defense let alone
guys like kendall fuller and sean davis
and thomas davis signed in the offseason
this is going to be a very formidable
defense that
yes can win them some games 16 to 13 17
to 14
whatever it may be but i'm with peter
more than anything
i look at the cowboys and i think we all
sit here and went
man they have a talented roster and i
just think with mike mccarthy and he
added juice to a new coaching
staff and mike you heard me complain all
the time last year about that doubtless
cowboys defense
same defense every play and they just
had way too much talent to let up some
of the yards and points they did in
certain games mike nolan being there
he's gonna throw plenty of curveballs on
a week to week basis so
i think it'll be a highly competitive
division man
is there a lot of good offensive
defensive linemen in this division
i mean these teams value battles up
front
but but i do think dallas has had a huge
off-season and a great draft
i mean against city lamb at 17. i'm with
peter i wish they would have got maybe a
defensive guy too
but cd lamb is one of those guys it's
just too hard to pass up
you know and to hear you guys praise the
cowboys i agree i agree
i agree with that we gotta let me let me
just say this real quick peter then we
gotta hit a break
the cowboys are paper champions it feels
like every year
they look great on paper every year they
gotta figure out this dak prescott
situation
we don't we spent the whole segment on
the nfc east
and none of us raised dak prescott uh
and i just thought of it now
like there's you're starting
quarterbacks not under contract
and you continue to delay and delay and
delay and the cost keeps going up and
up and up and what the hell are you
going to do and when are you going to do
it july 15 is the deadline
that is blaring out there if they don't
get a deal done with him by july 15
does he just hold out a training camp in
the preseason maybe he will
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports